[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily singer fka twigs
accuses actor shia labeouf
of abuse we break down her claims and
his response
the strange twist of a man accused of
breaking into tom brady's home
detectives thought their suspect was
heading for his florida home then find
he's a thousand miles away
the boyfriend of brianna taylor
surprisingly gets help paying his legal
fees
from tyler perry plus why a father
accused of murdering his son
wants a new trial an inside look into
the legal arguments in this hot car
death
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
singer fka twigs is suing her
ex-boyfriend shyla buff
for alleged abuse during their
relationship
according to the lawsuit the singer
whose real name is talia barnett
claims labeouf choked her slammed her
head against a car
and pulled out a gun while driving she
also claims he knowingly gave her
an std the buffer responded in an email
to the new york times
writing i have no excuses for my
alcoholism or aggression
only rationalizations i've been abusive
to myself
and everyone around me for years i'm
sorry to those i hurt
fka twigs took to twitter writing she
hopes that by sharing her experience
she can help others feel like they're
not alone
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney gija gonzalez along with terry
austin
terry i heard these allegations and i
was like wait where's the criminal case
because tort claims for sexual assault
and patterns of abuse
are fairly unique why isn't this in
criminal court or
am i wrong brian you are never wrong
this is an overlap between criminal
court and tort law which obviously is a
civil case
a tort is a wrongful act that injures
someone and
here we see that they're claiming
assault they're claiming battery they're
claiming
infliction of emotional distress and
they can do that
under tort law in a civil case and they
can also get
damages as a result of that so the
reward can be
substantial here and i think that's what
we're seeing
now gigi we're just reading tea leaves
here but could a criminal charge or
criminal case be on the horizon
or do you think because fka twigs uh
pursued civil charges
that she might not want to bring this
into a criminal court
well right just reading off of twig's
actions it seems that she doesn't want
to take the criminal route but that does
not mean that criminal charges aren't
imminent uh for example the gas station
incident if there were witnesses to the
event
if there was video surveillance that
caught the actions on camera
then california could very likely pursue
criminal charges against
shia labeouf for these uh for these
charges for these crimes
however if she's not willing to
cooperate with law enforcement
and file a police report against him uh
you know who knows what could happen but
if there's evidence outside of the
victim's testimony then california can
definitely bring charges against him
all right now terry shilobuff goes to
new york times and makes this kind of
non-apology apology what do you make of
that well you know he did it for pr
reasons but he actually admitted more
than he should have and it could very
well come back to hurt him
in the civil suit
i will definitely keep an eye on that
and to other celebrity legal issues
rapper little wayne has pled guilty to
federal weapon charges
the 38-year-old admitted to possessing a
gold-plated gun
and six rounds of ammunition authorities
say they found the items in the rapper's
luggage when he arrived in miami on a
private plane
in december 2019. little wayne whose
real name is dwayne michael carter
entered a guilty plea to possessing a
firearm by a convicted felon
he's scheduled to be sentenced in
january and faces up to 10 years in
prison
a cheerleader featured in a netflix
docu-series has been indicted in a
sexual exploitation case
jerry harris faces charges he played a
role in producing child pornography
federal authorities accused harris of
enticing an underage boy
to produce sexually explicit photos and
videos according to documents
harris pursued victims on social media
information in the case of a florida man
arrested for breaking into nfl
quarterback tom brady's
massachusetts home angela levy has a
suspected motive
police in brookline massachusetts say
zanini cenius traveled more than 1300
miles
to break into tom brady's mansion cenius
is 34 years old and police say he is
infatuated with the former patriots
quarterback
turned tampa bay buccaneer sidious
family reported him missing from martin
county florida
officials there thought he might be
going to tampa to find brady
instead he was found in brady's home in
brookline massachusetts
that home is now on the market and is
currently vacant since brady and his
wife now live in tampa
the alarm company actually was
monitoring their cameras
that the residents had inside and they
were able to see somebody in the home
which was great for us they relate that
information to our dispatchers and our
dispatchers let our officers know
um sort of play by play what was going
on in the home so that when our officers
got there
they located the suspect who was just
sitting on a couch
in the basement level of the home now
this isn't the first time that zanini
cenius has been in trouble when it comes
to tom brady last year
he was arrested after stealing a tom
brady signed jersey from the patriots
hall of fame museum
cenius also has some warrants out in the
foxboro massachusetts area
the judge in his case has ordered a
psychiatric evaluation
for law and crime daily i'm anginatt
levy
thanks ange definitely brings a whole
new meaning to fnatic
now to tennessee where a convicted
rapist and burglar are back in custody
after escaping prison and kidnapping two
men
officials say robert lee brown and
christopher osteen broke out of a
tennessee correctional institution
and kidnapped a highway department
employee at a boat ramp on the
mississippi river
the man was found blindfolded in a
wooded area
officials found his truck then learned
the duo tied up a henry county man in
his home
and stole his truck they were tracked a
thousand miles away to broward county
florida
brown's 18 year sentence for aggravated
rape was set to end
in 2022 and austin's eight year sentence
for burglary
was set to end in 2023
daring escape so close to the release
but still ahead on law and crime daily
why a father in prison for his son death
says he was wrongfully convicted
but first film and tv mogul tyler perry
makes a big donation to a legal defense
fund
where that money is going after the
[Music]
break
the boyfriend of brianna taylor is
getting some unexpected help paying his
legal fees
from tyler perry kenneth walker was with
brianna taylor in her apartment
when officers executed the deadly no
knock search war
walker fired one shot and was initially
charged with attempted murder of a
police officer
the charge was dismissed in may jonathan
manley was shot during the raid
and announced he's suing walker for
emotional distress
manly described entering taylor's
apartment in the police interview
two weeks after the shooting
right down the hallway there's a bedroom
door on the right
and there's a the male and a female the
male's
closest to the door so it's to my right
and as i turn the doorway
he's in a stretched out position with
his hands with a gun
and as soon as i clear he fires boom
and it was almost like at the shooting
range with two two things
flip at the same time and you gotta
shoot no shoot but i mean they were like
shoulder to shoulder my mind's going
this ain't right you know something's
off here
because all the doors i've made entry
and i've never seen this
and so i hit this corner and it goes
boom and as soon as the
as soon as the shot hit i could feel the
heat in my leg
and so i just returned fire i got four
rounds off
um and it was like simultaneous boom
boom boom boom boom
and then i went back and went down on
the side of the door and then reached
around and i think i got two more off
around the corner of the door and then i
could really feel the blood in my legs
so i reached out and felt it
my hand was full blood and i knew it hit
my femoral at that point walker
described the shooting in a police
interview
right before he was arrested
so it's a loud boom at the door first
thing she said
who is it no response so we like what
the heck
we both get up start putting on clothes
another knock at the door
she's like who is it loud at the top of
her lungs
no response so then i grab my gun which
is
legal like i'm licensed to carry
everything i've never even fired my gun
outside of a range
when we get out of the bed or whatever
like walking towards the door
the like the door like comes like off
the hinges
so i just let off one shot like i still
can't see who it is
or anything so now the doors like flying
open all out one shot and then all of a
sudden there's a whole lot of shots
and like we both just dropped to the
ground
a gofundme account for walker's defense
was nearly empty for weeks
until 100 000 was donated on sunday
a source confirms to local media it was
tyler perry
back with me our attorneys terry austin
and gigi gonzalez
terry what are your thoughts on
mattley's suit against kenneth walker so
far
you know i think this counter claim is a
bogus claim he's saying that there was
battery assault intentional
you know infliction of emotional
distress and they
the police were the ones who started
this whole event kenneth walker
was as he said in that clip defending
his home he had a gun he was licensed to
carry
so i don't think that these claims
should prevail
and hopefully they won't prevail because
i think kenneth walker is in the right
here
i tend to agree with you terry and let
me say this first where i get to gigi
first responders nurses officers doctors
they get
firefighters get harmed in the line of
duty all the time we definitely want
them to be safe but
when i look at these facts gigi do you
see any merit on this type of case where
someone executes a no-knock warrant and
gets shot by a licensed gun owner
fearing for their life
you know i haven't seen that but isn't
that the entire point of the second
amendment is to be able to protect
yourself and your loved ones
when you're inside of your own castle
your house against
unwanted intruders uh you know you have
a no knock warrant here that was
executed
wrongly uh to the point where it
inspired new legislation preventing no
knock warrants uh you know and then you
have them opening fire
i gotta be honest with you i can't see
how the nra and everybody's not coming
out in defense of kenneth walker
here he is exercising his second
amendment right to protect himself
and his loved ones while he's in his
house against unknown intruders and he's
being sued for that
it's pretty you know it's pretty wild to
see that and i'm looking forward to
seeing him prevail
in civil court yeah i mean kenneth
walker already
prevailed in one way shape or form with
the criminal cases being dropped
we'll see how the civil case goes as
well and when we come back a
father convicted of killing his son by
leaving him in a hot car
gets a second chance in court how
prosecutors got a guilty verdict the
first time around
next
[Music]
a georgia father convicted of killing
his son by leaving him in a hot car
is arguing for a new trial a jury found
justin ross harris guilty of murdering
22 month old cooper
harris was sentenced to life in prison
without parole
cooper's lifeless body was found in a
car seat in harris's suv
parked at his work harris called for
help seven hours after he parked his car
investigators say temperatures reached
into the high 80s
looking here at 9 25 17 is there
anything
in particular this video that you pulled
where we see the suspect's car coming
into the video
it said you should be in the top top
left is that it right there
is that it is okay okay
now the cars come to a complete stop on
the studio what is the time
uh the 9 25 39 925
398 go ahead and start the video back
again
okay i just paused it again did we see
at this point it's 9 25 56
do you see the door start to open i do
prosecutors said harris was distracted
by his multiple affairs
undercover officers found a former sex
worker harris allegedly met with three
times and got her to testify against him
they asked me if i had seen this person
they showed me
just the fake shot and automatically i
knew
what it was because clearly by that
point it had been on the news i really
hadn't watched the news too tough
you know i had heard fleeting rumors and
hearsay gossip about what was going on
but
as soon as i saw the picture and it was
like yeah i had seen him a couple of
times
that's when the broad scheme of what
exactly what was going on
who came to play so the first part when
you recognize him was it because
of your interactions with him in may
personally
okay and then later you kind of realize
what it was yes
okay on cross the defense questioned the
woman about how
certain she was that the defendant was
her client
and the first time he did see me was the
week of my birthday
which is when 19th
okay and when you said um
when you said first time he saw you you
said it was 15 minutes
and this would have been the week of the
18th yes
and was it the same
location at the econo lodge yes okay
and the only way that he would be able
to
locate you was your phone number on the
back page yes
okay because before then i haven't ever
seen him
but they applied i'm not even from the
area
that was the first trial but when we
come back we're giving you an inside
look into this motion for a new trial
why the defense says a simple memory
lapse and not foul play
is to blame
[Music]
now to the legal arguments of a father
convicted of murdering his son
by leaving him in a hot car to die his
defense says he
unintentionally left his child in the
back seat and called a memory expert in
order to prove it
what we had on the the morning of the
incident
was a change in routine
so on that morning what i had learned
was
that ross harris was running late
um he didn't follow through his typical
routine that morning
he he always shaved every morning that
morning he didn't shave because he was
in a big hurry
because he needed to attend an early
morning meeting
at home depot so he had planned
on his routine to when he was leaving
home
he was going to drop off cooper at
daycare and then perhaps go to
chick-fil-a or straight to
to work um but actually since he didn't
have breakfast he would have done
from home do daycare pick up the
breakfast at chick-fil-a
and then go directly to work so he had
planned
on doing his typical routine
the defense's expert says harris's
typical routine got interrupted causing
him to be forgetful
along the drive he received a message
and that was between home and
arriving at daycare the message he
received
indicated that the early morning meeting
had been delayed
so he didn't need to hurry to attend to
get to work
and so what i learned from my interview
with
uh ross harris was that since he was no
longer in a hurry
he decided to go to chick-fil-a
and have a sit-down breakfast with
cooper now this is something completely
out of the ordinary
he had almost never done this in
cooper's life
and so he has now changed his routine
his plan now is to go to breakfast with
cooper
and then after leaving chick-fil-a to
have an entirely
different approach an entirely different
route
from normal which was he would leave
chick-fil-a
take cooper to daycare and then from
daycare
he would go to work on cross the
defense's expert admitted that
forgetting a child in a car cannot be
minimized
of course forgetting a child is in a car
it can't be compared to forgetting to go
to a store
but it is a category of memory that is
consistent
under both conditions the failure to
remember
the child the failure to go to the store
involves a loss of awareness
of a plan to do something in the future
now
i happen to talk about forgetting to go
to a store
as one example that most people can
relate to
but this kind of memory failure has been
catastrophic under other conditions
but in this particular case or in any
case
where a parent has forgotten their child
in the car
if they did it on purpose intentionally
then none of this testimony about
prospective memory has any relevancy to
the case at all correct well that is why
in fact the criterion of
mine is to determine if the findings in
the case are consistent with it being a
memory failure
all right so let's talk about that you
originally started to talk with maddox
kilgore
uh mr harris's attorney back in 2014 is
that correct
oh that sounds correct yes all right and
was that before or
after you made commentary about mr
harris's case to headline
news a few days after the homicide
i think that was after i had been
invited to write that
op-ed memory or failure or intent that's
one of the major arguments here let's
bring back
in our experts terry this expert was
supposed to testify for the defense at
the first trial
but they didn't end up calling him could
that be a reason for a new trial and why
you know i think not having him at that
trial was a
big mistake dr diamond is a neurosurg
you're a neuroscientist and he's talking
about
memory he's talking about people who are
either on
autopilot or you know they're thinking
about something else so they're totally
not focusing and if you have sleep
deprivation
you know that's going to add to it so i
think his testimony would have
really helped to say that this was not
intentional
at all you know over 900 children have
died in hot cars since 1990 it's a
horrible
statistic but actually it's something
that does
happen now
gigi this one witness the sex worker the
the defendant's mistress he testified
sorry she testified and kind of made him
just look sleazy but it wasn't really
probative
to the murder charges how did that work
out and could that affect a new trial
well it worked out in the original trial
the state was able to secure a
conviction
and she definitely uh was able to make
her testimony work for her
she was someone who was caught by this
by the state and was charged
and was forced to flip and testify
against a defendant here
and her testimony was valuable because
it secured a conviction
so she was going to say whatever she
needed to say and what she had to say
had nothing to do with the crime at hand
it had to do with the sex act that
occurred weeks before
it had nothing to do with cooper or the
events on that day that led to cooper's
death
and you better believe that's going to
be a major issue on appeal they're going
to bring up
thank you terry and gigi for joining us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
[Music]
you